I'm joining us now the author of the new
book is a phenomenal book I can't put it
down resistance at all costs how Trump
haters are breaking America columnist
for The Wall Street Journal Fox News
contributor Kimberly Strasse along with
the author of the book power grab Fox
News contributor also jason Chaffetz
Republican congressman Matt Gaetz
earlier today was actually thrown out of
the impeachment inquiry why Matt I'm
sure you're a friendly guy it's very
bizarre Sean on September 12th about a
month ago the Judiciary Chairman
launched the impeachment inquiry and
today Adam Schiff removed me as a member
of the Judiciary Committee from the
deposition he was taking this is proof
that Democrats can't win a fair election
they can't win a fair debate and they
absolutely cannot run a fair impeachment
inquiry because they're stacking the
deck they're doing everything they can
to limit our access to witnesses and
evidence they're not allowing us to call
witnesses and by the way if Republicans
had a witness list it would be Adam
Schiff who would be a fact witness
because of the collusion that he was and
his staff are engaged in with the
whistleblower that they then lied about
so look we're gonna keep fighting to get
to the facts here but time and again we
see that Adam Schiff is running a
kangaroo court and that should matter
two senators who may have to ultimately
consider this impeachment that it was
done in a totally rough shot way even
Republicans didn't treat Bill Clinton
this bad they had the opportunity to
have minority subpoenas and have the
president's lawyers in the room asking
questions they went through that with
the Russia investigation they allowed us
to ask Muller questions and ask
Lewandowski questions they didn't like
the result so now they're trying to
reshuffle the deck and I think it's a
shameful day for the House of
Representatives they announced that all
they have many reasons if this one
doesn't work out we'll find another one
Nancy Pelosi said Kim the book is
phenomenal I think it's a defining
moment for the country I think you've
identified where we are tie that in also
to the Ukraine the ship issue the Pelosi
issue the impeachment madness and the
mob in the media they're allies this is
one of the damages that the resistance
is causing that I talked about in the
book we've had two modern impeachment
inquiries and in both cases the party in
charge bent over backwards to make sure
that it was done in a fair and open
manner because they understood that they
needed to treat
Pietschmann as the somber and serious
tool that it is improved to Americans
that they were conducting an inquiry in
a fair manner we now have a House
Democratic majority that hasn't even had
a vote and taken the accountability on
the floor to take responsibility for
this they're holding their proceedings
in secret they're denying the White
House the right to call their own
witnesses and Republicans the right to
cross-examine witnesses or to even be
present this is not how Americans expect
impeachment to be treated and these are
the kind of damage to institutions that
are going to be with us for a very long
time in this country and there are men
we won't have the country if we this
continues we're not going to have the
country which brings us to the IG report
congressman Chaffetz then take it a long
time and we heard the end of this week
now we're in the beginning of next week
I can never get a straight answer but
you know what at some point are we going
to see premeditated fraud on a FISA
Court and people held accountable spying
on a presidential campaign transition
and president it has been going on for
an exceptionally long time evidently
there's an intra-agency debate and
really a food fight if you will about
the classification issues remember in
the last report put out by Horowitz
there were only seven words or so that
were redacted the Democrats threw a fit
that they couldn't see the whole thing
this could have 1020 percent of the
report redacted senators based on that
is that director ray who is not shown
any willingness to clean up the greatest
law-enforcement agency in the world is
that him I have not seen any evidence
that director ray has been cooperative
but I think you're talking about other
agencies perhaps perhaps the CIA the NSA
there are others I think mr. clapper mr.
Brennan are behind the scenes fighting
as best they can in front of the camera
they're fighting as best they can I
think you need to look at what mr. Comey
had the director of the FBI and his
interaction with Brennan in particular
others were the white sort of collusion
was happening within our government and
overseas that's the deep concern shot
well amazing congrat
on your new book Kimberly amazon.com
Hannity comm same with Jason Matt great
job today
proud of you